welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with a
look at one of the communities most at
risk during the corona virus pandemic
Native Americans have long suffered from
inadequate health care and they have
higher rates of diseases such as
hypertension diabetes and heart disease
that can make kovat 19 infections even
worse this week we visited tribes in the
West to see how they are struggling to
get through this crisis it's hard to
imagine when you look at the vast vistas
in the rural West there's an
overcrowding problem here but there is a
problem and it's big on tribal lands
even here social distancing can be hard
to do I know some of the affected houses
out here in a city there's like 1314
people that live in a house so of course
they're gonna I think it's so Terry
Roberts is purchasing manager on the
Wind River Reservation in Wyoming home
to the Eastern Shoshone and the Northern
Arapaho tribes housing is limited
it took me six or seven years to get my
place so and that's after bouncing
around from from cousin's house you know
it's Native Americans you know we have
our sweat lodges that that people go
into we do our prayer ceremonies zina
Aragon has seven family members living
at her house there's a lot of families
that are having to live together just
for the necessity of paying bills and
car payments the overcrowded home
situation is at least 16 times the
national average
Kevin Allen CEO of the National Congress
of American Indians says federal funding
for housing has been frozen for decades
a violation of old treaties and now
feared as an agent to aid the spread of
the virus
it's a tinderbox where there's coded 19
situation we're getting word that the
Navajo Nation in southern Utah northern
Arizona is especially hard Navajo Nation
is into the land base is enormous and
covers several states but in their
highly populated areas that Traverse
you know large cases of confirmed
coronavirus infections there are more
than a thousand known cases in a place
lacking water we tell people to wash
their hands but a study showed 30
percent of the homes on navajo nation
don't have running water so how are they
going to do that 10 billion dollars in
federal relief money has been set aside
for direct funding to tribes and federal
Indian programs but right now there's a
battle brewing over how the federal
government should distribute the money
with Indian groups preparing to take the
battle to court we're worried that the
money won't get right to the tribes but
time is of the essence how dire is the
situation in Indian country I know our
tribal leaders are doing the best they
can to keep their communities safe all
that the dominoes are in place to fall
in a very coordinated fashion if we
don't get the attention we need we don't
get the resources we need that's why
this relief funding is so important with
limited resources tribal leaders are
improvising the Navajos have instituted
strict curfews requiring people to stay
home or face arrest to keep Outsiders
out at an entrance to the Pine Ridge
Reservation in South Dakota we found the
Oglala Sioux tribes road block one of
nine around the 2 million acre
reservation that has the dubious
distinction of being the poorest place
in America all across the state they
needed mean trying to test as many
people as they can so they know who has
it and who doesn't have it a Twin River
dr. Paul Ebert's team is ramped up
testing at a higher rate than the entire
state of Wyoming but they face another
kind of roadblock not everyone has a
phone
possible exposure but none of them had
fallen so getting the results to people
infected who tested positive means they
were main out there somewhere and it's
tough politics is entering this fray as
well as some of those communities are
trying to make sure that everyone gets a
bit of that relief money a special
thanks to Walker Dawson our DJ who who
went out there and shot so much of that
it's incredible what they are now
dealing with it's so important Michelle
the shed light on and I know this was so
important for you to do and when you
point out that it's become political we
don't have time for that right now for
these people they need the money they
need the help and even it's some really
basic levels really great report